bonjour Elsa bonjour mais est-ce que ce
serait pas votre baptême
je suis pas baptisée ah mais si oui tout
à fait
[Applaudissements]
catenas les tweets de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
la séquence j'ai envie de dire la France
insoumise d'abord comme beaucoup de gens
un grand sourire narquois vous savez
c'est un peu comme quand on découvre le
curé au bordel on a envie de se moquer
de lui parce qu'il nous a fait la morale
et puis après on le retrouve dans des
circonstances autres et ben les gens de
la France insoumise c'est la même chose
[Musique]
vous voulez pas du tout parler de
l'affaire 4 nains
que vous avez publié
monsieur je pèse mes mots tout le temps
c'est vous qui regrettez ce que vous
êtes en train de dire vous avez peser là
le rhinocéros blanc qui est juste là il
s'appelle SMOS
Ker
montre des décideurs dans le monde
politique ou dans le monde économique je
me dis qu'est-ce qu'ils auraient fait
d'abord en juin 40
j'ai tellement peur que tu me laisses
plus les hommes mangent de la viande
rouge plus ils sont sexistes c'est ce
que révéler dévoiler ce matin sur RMC
François cross de l'institutif à
l'origine d'une étude sur le sujet on
voit bien qu'on a une politique
croissante des enjeux liés à
l'alimentation qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
ça crée des clivages des clivages
d'ordre politique mais aussi d'ordre
sociétaux je dois dire parce que hier
j'ai cité le compte parodique de Madame
panier rue de nacher et effectivement
ensuite j'ai immédiatement rectifié mais
bien sûr les propos que j'ai fait tenir
à Madame panier une acier à Madame
bannir une hachée pardonnez-moi était
évidemment inexact c'était un conte
parodique
incarnation du Mal
le match
on se fait surprendre parfois par des
comptes parodiques mais parfois c'est
mal et je voilà je suis évidemment
responsable de cela immédiatement une
minute après j'avais déjà rectifié mais
il est bon de le redire ce qu'on fait
une erreur il faut tout simplement le
dire ce qui se qualifie de très viandes
sont sur-représentés dans les catégories
les plus à droite de l'échiquier
politique et sont souvent aussi un peu
plus sexistes que la moyenne à l'inverse
en fait les flexitariens ou les
végétariens eux présentent un profil
beaucoup plus je dirais progressiste
écolo progressistes et ils sont
notamment sur représentés dans les
électorats Mélenchon au Jadot
aujourd'hui il y a des choses qui
sortent sur PPDA qui il a pas empêché
vous pouvez rien dire sur Nicolas Hulot
je suis désolé pardon il y a il y a
absolument rien que les choses soient
clairement dites et je lui dis ici pas
de façon très
neutre puisque je suis avec Jacqueline
Lafont de son avocat
oh merde du Nord en train d'installer
une éolienne oui bon bonjour bonjour
l'équipe bonjour Julien je sais pas vous
qui vous m'entendez très bien là on sent
que la palle est en bas là vous êtes en
train de remonter
[Musique]
voilà il y a classement sans suite point
terminé rideau on arrête avec ça on
arrête mais le classement sans suite est
lié à la prescription des alors et alors
c'est l'application de l'État de droit
signifie que l'effet orienté est-ce que
vous avez vu